so when I first got into
self-improvement I had really bad social
anxiety talking to somebody I didn't
know very well especially if they were a
girl was really difficult for me even
carrying on a basic human conversation
was something that I didn't really know
how to do very well I'd always be stuck
in my head thinking about what I was
gonna say next and worrying about
whether they were impressed with me and
I also didn't have very many friends
people didn't really invite me anywhere
so I started searching on reddit for
answers you know kind of lurking through
self-improvement subreddits like I used
to do quite a bit back in the day and
there was a book recommendation that
kept on coming up in every single
self-improvement subreddit that I looked
at it seemed to be everyone's go-to book
they would recommend for people
struggling with social anxiety or
struggling with being able to maintain a
basic conversation and that book was how
to win friends and influence people by
Dale Carnegie it came as kind of a shock
to me because this book was published in
1936 in 2019 it's closer to the year
2100 than it is to when that book was
published yet in 2011 Time magazine
ranked it as the 19th most influential
book in American history so it doesn't
mess around
so I starting to get this vibe that it
was the Bible of human communication and
I gave it a read and it changed my life
I'm not saying that this book was
responsible for everything good that
ever happened in my life or anything
like that but what I do mean is that it
changed my perspective and I learned
some things from this book that I have
carried with me to this day I've never
forgotten and they've completely
transformed the way I interact with
people having conversations with pretty
much anybody is not an issue for me
anymore and people actually invite me to
stuff so I'm gonna go over some of the
most impactful lessons from the book how
to win friends and influence people and
hopefully it helps you out as much as it
helped me out just a preface before I
dive into these tips or these lessons or
whatever you want to call them they are
just tools all these things I'm about to
say
are just tools they're not absolute
rules they can be broken but that being
said they are very powerful tools that I
think work extremely well in most
situations especially this first one
that I'm about to dive into it's less of
a tip or a tool it's more like a
paradigm shift that you can apply to
pretty much your entire philosophy when
it comes to dealing with people and that
is lesson 1 it's all about the other
person it may come as no surprise to you
that everyone basically just thinks
about themselves what they've got going
on in their lives what they want to eat
for dinner
what are they stressing about what they
want to do tomorrow the vacation they
want to take next summer they're not
really thinking about you at all you
probably wouldn't be surprised to find
out that you primarily think about
yourself as well
and when you think about other people
it's always in the context of you it's
like does this person like me do they
think I'm stupid because I said this
thing
it's always about you everyone else
thinks that exact same way so in order
to become better with people you have to
realize this and see things from other
people's perspective people's favorite
hobby and people's favorite topic and
the one they're most comfortable talking
about is things to do with themselves so
if you want to become a good
conversationalist you have to become an
investigator in people try to get them
talking about what's going on in their
lives and you will never run out of
conversation which people sort of know
but they don't practice it because they
feel like they're not getting anything
out of the interaction you know by
entirely focusing on what the other
person has going on in their life you
know you're almost stepping on yourself
and not allowing your own personality to
shine or something like that but I found
that kind of the opposite is true when
you become genuinely interested in other
people and what they have going on in
their life they're a lot more likely to
return the favor a lot of people have
been in a situation or a conversation
where somebody starts talking about
their dreams and their ambitions and
their skills and things they've done and
then the other person just responds with
their dreams and their ambitions and the
things that they want to do and they
sort of just start it's like a
back-and-forth they're trying to one-up
each other and
nobody really gets anything out of the
conversation no one's really listening
they're just focusing on basically you
know what measuring but when you
actually listen to the person talk about
their ambitions and their skills and you
genuinely ask them pressing questions
about what their motivation was behind
this what they think they got out of it
etc etc and you actually practice being
genuinely curious not only would that
person really appreciate the fact that
you're actually asking genuine questions
and that you're listening they're way
more likely to ask you genuine questions
about yourself and you can generate a
pretty close friendship very quickly so
next time you dive into a conversation
with somebody new genuinely try to be an
investigator in what is going on in
their life what is making them tick and
try to get to know them and actually
listen lesson number two make them feel
valued now before I dive into this tip I
just want to say something a lot of
people think that this book how to win
friends and influence people and these
tips that I'm giving and the tips that
are available in the book that they're
somehow manipulative I don't see that as
true they're only manipulative if you
use them to manipulate somebody giving
somebody a genuine compliment or even if
you make it a habit to give someone a
genuine compliment only does good
putting somebody in a good mood by
complimenting their appearance a
personality trait or something that you
genuinely find good about them
often makes their day and they walk
around the office or town or whatever
they're doing with a kind of swagger in
their step all because you complimented
on something that you noticed that you
liked about them one of the greatest
ways you can make people feel valued is
to use their name and use it liberally
hey Joey how's it going oh hey Joey hey
guys look it's Joey that makes me feel
great when people use my name especially
if they don't know me very well or if I
just met them maybe one time and they
remembered my name that makes my day
like it makes me feel valued it makes me
feel like they actually remembered our
conversation even though they probably
didn't by using somebody's name it makes
people feel like you have a connection
just instantly the second way to make
people feel valued is to give genuine
compliments once you start practicing
empathy and start practicing seeing
things from another person's perspective
like the book is all about
then you
get really good at noticing things that
stand out from person to person and once
you get in the habit of vocalizing those
things you'll become somebody who people
gravitate towards and people just really
like being around once you start to
become an investigator in people you can
really start to psychoanalyze people and
compliment them on their actual
personality complimenting someone's
personality is often way more powerful
than just complimenting something thats
hanging off their body a necklace or
that sounded like there's a weird
telling somebody that they're an
extremely good listener and I really
appreciate it is a lot more powerful
than saying I like your shirt before our
final tip just a quick word from today's
video sponsor T Shanley okay so I
decided to reshoot this ad because I'm
noticing even more benefits of using T
Shanley on my skin so for those of you
who don't know T Shanley is a skin care
system for men designed to take the
complication out of good skin every
single month they ship you four
different components to your door number
one is the wash which you can use in the
shower that's what I do number two is
the scrub which you use twice a week
also in the shower and after your shower
if it's the morning you use the a.m.
moisturizer and if it happens to be at
night after your shower you use the PM
oyster Iser as you've been watching this
channel you've probably noticed I don't
have the greatest skin genetics so I've
never had like beautiful skin but I'm
getting closer
thanks to T Shanley you guys have
probably heard me talk about the slight
edge or the compound effect where simple
daily habits that don't seem to do a lot
equal a huge success later down the road
one area of my life where that's been
abundantly clear is my skincare routine
thanks to T's Handley better ideas
viewers get 20% off their first box so
click the link below if you want to take
advantage of that deal or just use the
coupon code better ideas I check out and
yeah I hope you enjoy it as much as I do
okay guys so take a look at this scene
from the Great Gatsby I don't even
really like this movie very much but
this is one scene that I remember it's
clear as day and I watch this like three
years ago this is the scene where
spider-man meets Leonardo DiCaprio I
forget the character's names look at the
way this interaction goes you see
[Music]
I'm GATS
his smile was one of those rare smiles
that you may come across four or five
times in life it seemed to understand
you and believed in you just as you
would like to be understood and believed
in sorry old sport I thought you knew
please just I don't know what to say
please forgive me it's quite all right
had so much to drink yes mr. Gatsby sir
Chicago I'm taking my new hydroplane out
in the morning would you like to go with
me what time when he meets Gatsby for
the first time he feels like there is
understanding behind his smile as
powerful as Gatsby is he still took the
time to put his hand on his shoulder
look him in the eye and really pay
attention and focus on what Peter Parker
was saying so the last tip is focus
pretend that the person in front of you
is the only person in the entire world
and this channel is all about focus the
skill of focus translates well to human
interaction as well if you learn to
minimize your cell phone and social
media use if you learn to focus on
slower paced things and really honing in
on things you find boring even boring
conversations then you'll be able to
make people feel valued and appreciated
and listens to that's all that people
want even when they go on long spiels
about all their goals and ambitions all
they want to hear is that is incredible
you know good for you
so why not make somebody's day by
actually pretty even pretending that you
care sometimes that's all people need
they just need somebody who pretends
like they care bonus points if you
actually learn to care so guys these are
just some of the lessons I learned from
how to win friends and influence people
by Dale Carnegie I'll put a link in the
description for you to pick up your copy
on Amazon I'm not gonna make it an
affiliate link or anything like that
it's probably pretty cheap if you have
an e-reader like a Kindle or Kobo you
probably find it online like an online
PDF if you just Google how to win
friends and influence people dot PDF if
you liked this video make sure to hit
like because when you like it the
algorithm knows that it's a high quality
video and it helps people see the video
if you're lurking here and you haven't
subscribed
hit that subscribe button and then hit
that Bell icon so you don't miss future
uploads if you have any suggestions for
videos you want me to cover in the
future let me know in the comment
section below
that's all for today thank you for
watching and we'll catch you in the next
video